[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
et au sénat avec à mes côtés oriane
mancini bonjour à yann genty voix et
cette semaine notre invité est sophie
tailler polian sénatrice apparenté
socialiste du val-de-marne
vous êtes membre du mouvement
générations bonjour à vous bonjour et
cette semaine l'assemblée nationale a
adopté la loi anti-casseurs à une large
majorité mais on retiendra un chiffre 50
c'est le nombre de députés de la
république en marche qui se sont
abstenus une première sous le
quinquennat
le sénat lui poursuivre et l'examen de
la loi pâte pour la croissance et la
transformation des entreprises
les sénateurs de droite et de gauche se
sont alliés pour rejeter d'une des
mesures phares du texte la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris est de la française
des jeux est alors que la mobilisation
des gilet jaune et le grand débat se
poursuive les députés ont débattu
mercredi des avantages fiscaux réservés
aux plus aisés les oppositions on crie à
l'injustice fiscale
bruno le maire lui a redit son
opposition au retour de j f et on
commence par le vote de la loi contre
les casseurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une loi qui a fait de la casse au sein
du groupe la république en marche 50
députés macro nice se sont abstenus lors
du vote du texte mardi après midi une
première depuis le début du quinquennat
un malaise qui s'exprime sur un fond de
critiques contre une loi qualifiée de
liberticide c'est l'interdiction
administrative de manifester qui
justifie ce trouble explications elsa
mondain gava majorité de 140 pour 387
contre 92 l'assemblée nationale a adopté
un vote large pour adopter la
proposition de loi anti casseurs mais au
sein du groupe majoritaire 50 voix ont
manqué une abstention record pour des
députés en marche
habitué à la discipline un fait
politique que tente de minimiser tour à
tour les présidents du groupe et du
parti il n'y a pas de malaise
il ya eu un travail collectif qui
aboutit au résultat d'aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de nos collègues peuvent
avoir des hésitations parce que c'est un
texte qui touchent à quelque chose
d'essentiel
je respecte cette position l'essentiel
c'est que il n'y ait pas eu de votre
compte de la part de députés de la
république en mars il peut y avoir du
débat au sein de notre groupe
je crois pas qu'ils de vote contre la
loi et donc que nous avons trouvé les
bon équilibre dans un groupe qui débat
qui vit et c'est bien normal c'est la
démocratie
chez les abstentionnistes on se félicite
du message envoyé
je n'imaginais pas quand même au temps
c'est ça parle ça parle et ça montre à
quel point cette ce texte ne convient
pas à beaucoup d'entre nous mais ne leur
parlez pas de fronde eux n'y voit que du
débat ça provoque quelques divisions
mais c'est pas très grave
encore une fois il faut comprendre que
ce groupe là c'est un peu une sorte de
coworking de la politique c'est assez
nouveau sac à des gens qui sont pas
forcément d'accord des majorités un peu
fluctuante et ça fait pas de nous des
frondeurs c'est pas de nous des gens qui
fracturent le groupe
je crois que plus on challenge le
gouvernement plon le renfort 50
abstentions la preuve d'un groupe qui
s'affirme pour les uns qui se fracturent
pour les autres alors sophie taille et
polluant est ce que vous salué le vote
de ces cinquante députés ma chronique
qui se sont abstenus écoutez je sais pas
si je les salue je pense quand ils ont
fait en l'ordre alors en leur conscience
cependant on voit bien qu'il ya eu de
fortes pressions pour ne pas qu'ils
votent contre
et je pense que certains d'entre eux
auraient bien aimé voter contre et que
cette loi liberticide qu'elle est
appelée un vote contre car elle revient
sur une des libertés fondamentales qui
est celle de manifester et elle place le
gouvernement en situation de dire qui a
le droit de manifester et qui n'a pas le
droit
c'est inacceptable on va revenir sur le
fond de la loi mais sur ce qui s'est
passé lors du vote est ce que vous dites
qu emmanuel macron voit sa majorité se
fissurer ou est ce que finalement vous
dit que ce texte restera une exception
je pense que emmanuel macron sur un
certain nombre de choses il fait ce
qu'il avait dit sur la question fiscale
et nous y reviendrons il avait annoncé
la couleur et on voyait bien un candidat
à la présidentielle qui était très
matrix et par l'idéologie néolibérale
mais cela dit sur le plan des libertés
publiques
sur le plan de la question des migrants
il avait affiché un bel humanisme et
bien c'est là dessus qu'on voit qu'il
revient totalement sur la belle image
qu'il avait voulu vendre et que c'est un
président autoritaire c'est un président
qui n'hésite pas pour des questions de
communication à revenir sur des libertés
fondamentales et c'est un président qui
n'hésite pas non plus à appliquer une
politique je dirais cruel et absolument
pas humaniste sur la question des
migrants
mais maintenant c'est sur ces questions
que la fracture pour inscrire dans la
majorité tout comme elle s'était créé
peut-être pendant le quinquennat
hollande sur les sujets plutôt
économique écouté pendant le quinquennat
hollande ya aussi la déchéance de la
nationalité qui a beaucoup marqué sur
ces questions de libertés fondamentaux
le d'égalité d'humanisme moi je pense
qu'en tout cas une grande fracture avec
le peuple de gauche qui avaient voté
pour emmanuel macron par sens par un
certain sens des responsabilités qu'on
peut regretter aujourd'hui et j'appelle
vraiment tous ceux et toutes celles qui
pensaient voir en emmanuel macron un
humaniste à revoir leur jugement mais je
pense qu'ils l'ont déjà fait parce que
depuis vingt mois ce qu'on voit c'est
vraiment le contraire de cela mais c'est
à dire est ce que parce que c'est vrai
que les 54 100 sioniste sont plus la
plupart des gens issus des rangs
socialistes issus de la gauche est ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça tapait lille et
concernent à ce que vous leur tendez la
main ces abstentionnistes moi je prends
j'appelle les gens à prendre leurs
responsabilités une abstention sur un
texte qui remet en cause une liberté
fondamentale ne suffit pas à se racheter
une bonne conscience
et si après on continue à appliquer un
certain nombre de choses à accepter un
certain nombre de choses de ce type
juste en s'abstenant pour avoir bonne
conscience mais ça ne suffit pas parce
que là on touche à quelque chose de
fondamental et tout cela réside dans la
façon dont ça va être appliquée mais une
loi elle reste elle reste et au fur et à
mesure que les choses évoluent on
l'appliquent de façon plus ou moins
différentes et on va assister à des
débordements et pour moi j'ai la bonne
conscience mais bien sûr c'est de la
bonne conscience face à face à ce
domaine en fait rien ça n'empêche rien
d'une situation qui s'est aggravée au
regard des libertés publiques et ce
n'est pas la première fois puisque il ya
aussi la loi antiterroriste il ya aussi
eu un certain nombre de décisions qui
vont contre cette vision de damon d'un
emmanuel macron humaniste il est temps
qu'ils prennent conscience qu'ils sont
qu'ils sont dans un jeu qui est très
dangereux pour notre démocratie
s'abstenir ne suffit pas en même temps
vous les voyez un ces manifestants plus
en plus violents ils s'attaquent à des
commerçants aux forces de l'ordre
est ce qu'il ne fallait pas durcir la
législation la législation était déjà je
dirais suffisamment suffisamment dur et
il ne faut certainement pas restreint
les libertés publiques
vous savez c'est pas en cassant le
thermomètre qu'on règle le problème
si les gens on tue aussi 7,7 cette
dérive violente un certain nombre de
personnes pas tous c'est aussi parce
qu'il ya une il ya une incapacité à se
faire entendre autrement
d'ailleurs c'est quand ils ont commencé
à doullens qu'ils ont gagné donc moi je
ne qu'ils ont gagné 10 milliards d'euros
enfin on pourrait revenir sur le fait
qu'ils les aient vraiment gagner pas
parce qu'on ne sait toujours pas qui va
vraiment régler la facture
mais ce que j'observe c'est que il en
est arrivé à un épuisement démocratique
au contraire il faudrait prendre en
compte le fait que quand il ya des
manifestants cela veut dire quelque
chose et on ajuste sa politique
or depuis de nombreuses années et
singulièrement là et bien les
manifestations ne changeait rien ne
changeait rien donc c'est ça qu'il faut
faire c'est qu'il faut savoir être
l'allemagne où les gens n'ont oui il l'a
écoutée que la violence alors moi je
regrette très fortement ces violences
mais ce que je regrette aussi c'est que
dans cette loi anti casseurs on ne parle
jamais des violences policières qui sont
pourtant qui sont pourtant de plus en
plus avérée ya plus d'une centaine d'
enquêtes qui sont ouvertes aujourd'hui
sur les violences policières qui ont
touché pour la plupart des militants ou
des manifestants qui n'étaient en aucun
cas violent et on le voit aujourd'hui il
ya une dérive sur la question notamment
des flashball là que fait le
gouvernement il n'y il n'y alors même
qu'on utilise ses armes qui peuvent
quand même éborgné qui peuvent attenter
à l'intégrité physique des gens de
manière durable et il n'y moi je pense
que c'est une attitude qui est
irresponsable
la loi vise tout de même les personnes
qui auraient commises des atteintes
graves à l'intégrité physique des
personnes ainsi que des dommages
importants biens ou des actes violents
lors de précédentes manifestations sont
des garanties qu ont été apportées lors
de la récriture à l'assemblée elles ne
sont pas suffisantes selon vous qui
jugent de cela c'est ça la question
évidemment qu'il faut je dirais réguler
le droit de manifester qui en est le
juge
est-ce que c'est justement une autorité
indépendante le pouvoir judiciaire des
juges indépendants ou est ce que c'est
le préfet qui agit au nom de l'état au
nom du gouvernement
on ne peut pas être juge et partie quand
on a une manifestation contre soi on ne
peut pas choisir les bons et les mauvais
manifestants soit même si non tu n'es
plus la démocratie la démocratie c'est
la séparation des pouvoirs et là ce
qu'on observe quand même c'est qu'on a
un pouvoir législatif notamment à
l'assemblée nationale qui est très au
garde à vous moi je connais des députés
en marche qui voulaient voter contre
on dira c'est la liberté sont abstenus
il voulait voter contre
on leur a mis une grosse pression pour
ne pas le faire et ce que j'observe qui
leur a mis une grosse pression sur le
genre
qui personnellement mais vous voyez bien
s'était dit dans votre reportage
on est contents il n'y a pas eu de votre
contre donc on voit bien qu'ils ont
monnayé le fait de ne pas avoir de
problème après dans le groupe
en discutant uniquement sur l'abstention
donc tout cela et est irresponsable je
crois au regard des enjeux
allez on va placer au sénat qui a achevé
cette semaine l'examen de la loi pacte
pour la croissance et la transformation
des entreprises
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
examen difficile pour bruno le maire
cette semaine bruno le maire qui porte
cette loi il a dû faire face à une
alliance des sénateurs de droite et de
gauche qui ont rejeté l'une des mesures
phare du texte la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris est de la française
des jeux
mais quelle fille de l'erc pour
l'adoption 246 contre 78 le sénat a
adopté l'article 44 et supprimer la
privatisation d'aéroports de paris a
donc été rejeté par les sénateurs à la
faveur d'une alliance droite gauche
une alliance de circonstance qui n'a pas
échappé au ministre de l'économie la
recomposition politique française nous
réserve encore bien des surprises avec
la vente d'adé paix pour une durée de 70
ans l'état espérait 8 milliards d'euros
une somme qui aurait dû alimenter un
fonds pour l'innovation à hauteur de 250
millions d'euros par an via un placement
boursier
un raisonnement économique illusoire
pour les communistes
s'il ya aucun krach financier occulte
chute de courbe
alors si vous connaissez un produit qui
va nous rapporter sur les soixante dix
prochaines années
deux ans et demi pour cent je vous
confie mon pel d'autant qu'à des paires
apporte aujourd'hui près de 180 millions
d'euros par an à l'état
avec des perspectives en hausse pour
l'avenir alors pourquoi vendre
s'interroge la droite sénatoriale
autant je comprends une privatisation
quand une entreprise publique ne marche
pas et ne peut pas marcher tant qu'elle
est tenue par les règles publiques
je comprends franchement c'est une
entreprise stratégique qui fonctionne
gardez là pour les socialistes est un
état mal en point qui cherche de
l'argent quitte à répéter des erreurs
comme la privatisation des autoroutes
s'il n'y avait pas d'exemples dans le
passé on pourrait vous excuser croire à
l'inexpérience mais il y à cet exemple
de ces autoroutes ont beaucoup
aujourd'hui conteste la pertinence de la
privatisation
pour le gouvernement le salut passera
peut-être par l'assemblée nationale qui
aura le dernier mot en commission mixte
paritaire
au grand dam du sénat sophie calle
polian pourquoi ces privatisations vous
semble-t-elle une erreur eh bien elle ne
semble une grave erreur parce que là
nous sommes sur sur adp notamment sur
aéroports de paris sur un actif
stratégique sur un actifs rentables
il n'ya donc
aucune bonne raison et les arguments
financiers de financer un fonds
d'innovation de rupture ne tiennent pas
parce que les dividentes rapportés par
cette entreprise sont au niveau de ce
que souhaite mettre monsieur le maire
pour financer les entreprises
d'innovation donc on voit là c'est
incompréhensible au regard des délais
des raisons qui sont donnés en plus il
s'agit d'un monopole parce que il n'y a
pas d'autres gros aéroport da ce niveau
là en france et donc quelque part on
pense même que c'est inconstitutionnel
donc il ya énormément de raisons tant la
fois juridiques que financière que de
bonne gestion
est ce que il est de bonne gestion de
vendre un actif qui rapporte autant
et est ce qu'il est de bonne gestion de
vendre un actif qui est si stratégique
une infrastructure comme celle là doit
rester sous gestion publique
on veut se sera déclarée
inconstitutionnelle c'est ça mais coûté
en tout cas il ya un certain nombre de
juristes qui s'interrogent pour quant au
fait que les aéroports de paris soit un
monopole de fait et que donc ce serait
totalement inconstitutionnelle je pense
qu'il y aura des actions là-dessus
effectivement des actions c'est-à-dire y
êtes vous vraiment concret du conseil
constutionnel où je sais que les
syndicats y réfléchissent eux c'est que
des groupes composés qui réfléchit bien
sûr bien sûr parce que nous pensons que
c'est en fait c'est un monopole de fait
au regard de la place de l'aéroport de
paris tant du point de vue de charles de
gaulle + orly plus le bourget et c'est
que c'est un monopole de fait qui est
qui est constituée dans notre pays par
ces par ses infrastructures alors bruno
le maire a dit nous entourons ces
opérations de toutes les garanties pour
la protection des intérêts stratégiques
de l'état vous n'y croyez pas et à
chaque fois on nous fait le coup alors
revenez sur angie autres privatisations
présente dans la loi pacte on va y
revenir
oui mais on nous dit maintenant mais
font revenir sur la garantie qu'on avait
mystère qu'on avait accepté de faire
d'ouvrir le capital d'énergie parce
qu'il y avait des garanties at elle
garanti qu'en femmes inscrire dans la
loi le marbre de la loi etc
puis quelques années plus tard on
revient et on enlève donc si vous voulez
c'est garanti là ne nous semble pas du
tout pas du tout véritablement solide
mais au delà des garanties il y as que
c'est une bonne opération mais ce n'est
pas une bonne opération que de vendre un
actif qui est aussi rentable avec des
perspectives de développement
sont avérées importante l'importante
augmentation du trafic aérien est prévu
et donc cela va rapporter
pourquoi se séparer bas j'ai voulu dire
pourquoi parce que le gouvernement a
peur d'un chiffre ce chiffre c'est 100%
de la dette sur le pib
il veut absolument pas qu'on atteigne ce
100 % dont qu'il dégonfle
artificiellement la dette de la france
en vendant des actifs qu'il va pouvoir
vendre facilement qu'il va pouvoir
vendre cher pourquoi parce que ce sont
des actifs très précieux et très
rentable
on l'a entendu dans le sujet c'est
l'assemblée nationale qui aura le
dernier mot sur ce texte malgré tout ce
vote négatif du sénat à droite et gauche
réunies
vous espérez qu'ils puissent faire
infléchir le gouvernement sur ces
privatisations
écoutez moi ce que j'ai dit à bruno le
maire pendant le vote du au sénat
pendant le débat au sénat
c'est que je pense que quelque part il
n'a pas le droit de faire cette
privatisation là alors il a le droit
juridiquement de faire passer au sénat
ou à l'assemblée
ce projet de loi mais politiquement
moralement at il le droit de privatiser
d'infrastructures comme celle là alors
même que dans le pays les gens se trouve
scandaleux aujourd'hui la privatisation
des autoroutes
les français ne sont pas d'accord et moi
j'appelle vraiment est ce que tout le
monde puisse se saisir de ce vote du
sénat qui est unanime sur tous les bancs
du sénat alors que pourtant des
différences politiques il y en a et
elles sont quand même très visible tous
les maux tous les instants de la vie
démocratique du sénat mais là nous nous
sommes unis pour dire que ce n'était pas
une bonne idée
moi j'appelle vraiment les citoyens et
citoyennes à ceux à se mobiliser sur
cette question parce que je crois qu'il
n'y a pas de majorité en france au
niveau du peuple au niveau des citoyens
pour accepter une telle privatisation au
regard de l'exemple notamment des
autoroutes sa privatisation d'énergie en
revanche a été votée elle pose moins de
problème elle pose moins de problème
visiblement à la droite sénatoriale nous
elle nous en pose tout autant parce que
nous considérons que pour ce qui
concerne l'achat de gaz l'achat
d'énergie
ça reste stratégique il ya aussi la
question des réseaux qui reste pour nous
stratégique
là encore on est sur le fait de l'état
qui se défausse qui n'a plus de vision
vraiment de d'intervention dans
l'économie jusque qui régule mais on
voit bien que souvent la régulation est
insuffisante pour lutter contre l'aspect
des brides et du capitalisme aujourd'hui
on en vient notre troisième thème lisf
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rétablir les ss est l'une des
principales revendications de nombreux
gilet jaune une revendication aussi du
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale qui a choisi ce thème cette
semaine pour un débat dans l'hémicycle
la fiscalité des plus hauts revenus a
donc de nouveau et l objet de vives
passes d'armes entre le gouvernement et
les bancs de la gauche résumé signé
laszlo gelabert c'est un sujet sensible
au coeur de la contestation des gilet
jaune
les députés ont débattu mercredi sur les
avantages fiscaux mis en place par le
gouvernement en faveur des français les
plus aisés
notre pays n'a jamais autant fait en
aussi peu de temps pour un si petit
nombre
ainsi depuis la prise de fonction de
cette majorité en 2017
les réformes fiscales ont été menées
tambour battant dans le collimateur de
la gauche le sentiment d'injustice
fiscale
nourri par la suppression de l'isf
l'impôt sur la fortune mais avec vous on
peut désormais avoir des millions en
banque des yachts des chevaux de course
des jets privés mais payer des impôts
aux mêmes tout le monde
deux cent trente huit mille
contribuables ne payent donc plus
d'impôt sur la fortune
autre point de friction dont l'évasion
fiscale françois ruffin interpelle bruno
le maire ce sujet
quand arrive ce texte promis par le
président de la république sur les
avantages indus de dirigeants et les
évasions fiscales
à droite la critique est la même julien
aubert accusent le gouvernement de taxer
les classes moyennes on taxe ceux qui ne
peuvent pas s'évader
les mêmes qui sont éternellement taxable
et parce qu'on sait très bien aussi que
la souveraineté fiscale de la france
lorsqu'il s'agit d'aller s'attaquer à
plus gros que soi je pense notamment aux
gars femme est beaucoup plus compliquée
à exercer
fidèle aux engagements du gouvernement
bruno lemaire défend la suppression de
l' isf ou encore la réduction de l'impôt
sur les sociétés pour le ministre de
l'économie
la multiplication des taxes ne réduit
pas les inégalités que notre système
fiscal et redistributif mais que les
inégalités à la racine en france reste
scandaleusement élevés et c'est bien
l'honneur de cette majorité que de
vouloir traiter les problèmes à la
racine par l'éducation par le travail et
par l'emploi plutôt que par
systématiquement l'augmentation des
impôts et des taxes
les dispositifs fiscaux du gouvernement
sont en cours d'évaluation
les conclusions seront rendues à
l'automne prochain sophie taille polian
que résoudrait le retour de l' isf ben
il rapporterait 5 milliards d'euros à la
france par an
je pense qu'on aurait on saurait quoi
quoi faire de cette de cet argent parce
que l'impôt sert quand même à financer
des services publics
il sert à financer l'éducation il sert à
financer les hôpitaux alors ce que
j'observe c'est que pour équilibrer le
budget de la sécurité sociale
on a encore serré la vis aux hôpitaux
on a aussi serrer la vis aux retraités
avec le fait de ne plus indexer les
retraites sur le coût de la vie donc je
pense qu'avec 5 milliards d'euros vous
pourrez déjà remettre un coupon de 1 5
milliard d'euros sur les personnes qui
payent les sf et bien du coup partirait
à l'étranger
alors on dit toujours ça et depuis les
années depuis le début du 20e siècle
ce qu'on observe c'est que globalement
le bercy évalue entre 15 et 20 millions
d'euros ce qui échappe ce qui échappait
donc sur 5 milliards je pense que ça
vaut quand même le coup
voyez de et puis je pense que y compris
moralement pour une histoire de deux
justices de sentiment de justice qui est
aujourd'hui tellement bafouée bien ce
serait bien de revenir sur des taxation
plus importante pour ceux qui ont des
revenus plus importants alors le
président emmanuel macron a dit qu'il ne
toucherait pas à cette mesure cependant
22 députés la république en marche ont
proposé cette semaine une forme de
nouvel isf il explique que si la mesure
ne portait pas ses fruits et bien il
pourrait conditionner cette exonération
d'impôt à l'investissement dans les pme
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
écoutez je
pense que il faut arrêter de faire des
ppl qui conditionne et s'est
complexifiée je pense qu'il faut
remettre un impôt sur le patrimoine et
sur les hauts revenus qui soit très
claire qui soit lisible et je pense
aussi qu'il faut travailler à faire en
sorte que la fiscalité des entreprises
soit plus juste aujourd'hui en france
entre les très grandes entreprises qui
optimise qui voire parfois ont des
politiques d'évasion fiscale et des
petites entreprises
il ya une différence de l'ordre de 14%
du taux d'imposition donc c'est là
dessus qu'il faudrait agir parce qu'il
ya des niches fiscales qui sont
surexploités sûr utilisé de manière pas
légitime par des grandes entreprises que
les petites n'ont pas les moyens de
faire notamment je pense au crédit
d'impôt recherche qui on le sait est
surexploité par les uns au détriment
finalement des autres en un mot le parti
socialiste a lancé début janvier
l'initiative d'un référendum
d'initiative partagée pour rétablir les
sf on rappelle qu'il faut 100 85
signatures de parlementaires
où en êtes vous alors nous nous nous
travaillons nous en sommes presque
presque au but nous espérons encore
convaincre quelques quelques collègues à
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat
en tout cas c'est nous n'y arrivons pas
ce sera certainement parce que des
députés ou des sénateurs en marche qui
d'un côté disent qu'ils veulent bien
d'autres côté ne veulent pas ne
signerait pas alors on va terminer avec
le grand débat national un emmanuel
macron a reçu toute la semaine les chefs
de groupe et de partis représentés au
parlement pour parler de ce grand débat
et de son issue avec une question qui
divise faut-il organiser un référendum
le jour de l'élection européenne
question posée à edouard philippe par
les sénateurs lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement c'était
mardi
écoutez le premier ministre je ne crois
pas qu'un instrument unique soit de
nature à traiter l'ensemble des
questions qui auront été évoquée pendant
le grand débat le scrutin qui
interviendra le 26 mai pour les
européennes sera un scrutin d'une
importance considérable absolument
considérable pour la construction
européenne et pour notre pays
il faut que le débat ait lieu il faut
que les gens disent clairement que les
responsables politiques que nos
concitoyens disent clairement ce qu'il
souhaite
s'agissant de la construction européenne
ce qu'ils veulent assumer il s'agissant
de la construction européenne nous avons
tous à gagner à la clarté du débat en la
matière j'en suis intimement convaincu
et tout ce qui permettrait ou pardon
tout ce qui aurait pour effet de
remettre en cause la clarté du débat
serait probablement écartée c'est
d'autant plus vrai que référendum ou pas
sur le sénateur depuis très longtemps
les élections européennes sont le moment
où on parle finalement assez peu des
élections européennes
et beaucoup de questions politiques
nationales nous le savons tous nous
l'avons tous vécu et nous n'avons pas
envie que cela recommence se fit taillé
et poli ans vous étiez dans l'hémicycle
à l'heure des questions d'actualité
qu'est ce que vous avez compris la
réponse du premier ministre qu'on vient
d'entendre écouter ce que j'ai compris
c'est que le premier c'est pas forcément
toujours très en phase avec le président
de la république en tout cas ce que j'ai
compris et ça m'a rassuré c'est qu'il
n'y avait pas de consensus au sein de la
majorité pour organiser un référendum en
même temps qu'une élection europe que
l'élection européenne ça je m'en
félicite parce que nous avons vraiment
besoin d'avoir un débat ouvert
intéressant sincère sur les questions
européennes qui sont quand même
extrêmement importante on l'a vu à la
sur la sphère alstom siemens c'est quand
même aussi l'orientation de leurs de
l'hôte de cette europe très libérale qui
qui qui pose qui pose question parce que
c'est là dessus que le stum et siemens
ne s'allieront pas pour la concurrence
libre et non faussée
donc ça ça me semble une bonne chose
après le référendum reste reste possible
mais est ce que le président souhaitera
le faire tout seul en vertu de l'article
11 ou est ce que on aura une réponse je
dirais plus large c'est quand même la
question qui reste posée parce qu'on
sait toujours pas qui consultent il
lance des ballons d'essai dans la presse
on voudrait comme un petit peu de clarté
sur où ce grand débat national
ok parfois être assimilé à un show
présidentiel en bras de chemise ou
est-ce que ça cela nous conduit à vous
dit qu'il est possible
est-ce qu'il est souhaitable est ce que
vous vous appelez à cette solution de
sortie de crise mais moi je pense que la
solution de sortie de crise et une
réorientation de la politique sociale et
économique de ce gouvernement c'est à
dire répondre aux aspirations des gens
ça je pense pas que ça puisse se faire
par un référendum uniquement ça peut
aussi j'ai appelé bruno le maire a
proposé au président de la république de
faire un
faire un dogme sur la privatisation d
adp ils veulent privatiser adp mais qui
vérifie auprès du peuple français s'il
serait d'accord pourquoi pas sks que du
coup vous redoutez que les réponses de
l'exécutif à cette crise d g jona ce
grand débat finalement soit des réponses
uniquement institutionnels et pas des
réponses sociales que vous appelez de
vos voeux il faut pas qu'une réponse
tactique essayer de sauver sa peau les
sauver et sauver la france
donc si c'est un référendum uniquement
sur quelques questions dont on sait
qu'elles sont majoritaires et parfois
démagogiques mais ça ne marchera pas de
toutes manières soit le goût le
président gagnera ce référendum et avec
une très faible participation et donc ça
ne changera rien à la situation de sa
déconnexion avec ce que veulent les
français soit ce sera un plébiscite
contre lui donc je pense pas je pense
qu'il faut ressortir sortir de cette
crise en mettant vraiment tout le monde
autour de la table et en travaillant sur
un projet fédérateur pour les françaises
et les français un projet de justice
sociale et un projet de transition
environnementale
mais ce sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup se fit à l'épaule et honda va
rester avec nous cette semaine merci
steam on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle semaine
d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]